bien après les bronzés de barcelone en
92 les barjots de ridjali champion du
monde en 95 les charlots qui ratèrent
d'une marche le podium olympique en 96
lycos touches sont champions du monde de
hand ball et voici daniel costantini
oui
je peux permettre jambes ré handball
j'ai dit quoi hand ball à jeudi en bol
c'est pas grave
noori a il faut dire football et
handball
voilà oui oui oui oui ça ne pas mes
origines et le trou de balle il a fallu
la faire
alors daniel vous êtes entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de handball et la
france décidément gyan a été champion
avec les pieds dans le mondial et dans
l'euro maintenant des champions avec les
mains non et avec le reste si elle
entend qu'on est champion c'est génial
vive la france voilà alors on vous
qualifie souvent d'électron libre et
votre devise est vachement bien c'est ne
m'en veuillez pas j'ai eu des milliers
d'adversaires et c'est vrai qu'on
reconnaît la valeur d'un homme a au nom
de ses adversaires
donc vous êtes quelqu'un de vachement
bien je suis blindé est blindée alors le
4 février un vrai bonheur là parce que
la france avait été donc 4e aux jo
d'atlanta en 96 ce n'est pas terrible à
signer 6e et là c'était la victoire
énorme
après prolongations toujours un c'est
bon les français c'est toujours dans les
prolongations qui c'est encore plus beau
hein on va regarder tout ça manille